okay today I'm going to talk to you
about velocity time graphs I'm going to
show you a few features of a velocity
time graph and I'm going to show you how
to calculate the total distance traveled
so what Abby's begin with is I'm just
going to draw some lines on here and
then in a minute we'll discuss what they
actually mean so let's have something
that looks like this
okay so this is just tracking the
journey of a moving object now on a
velocity time graph we have time on the
x axis this is exactly the same on a
distance time graph we always have time
on the x axis the big difference is
between a velocity time graph and a
distance time graph is we have velocity
instead of distance on the y axis
remember velocity is basically how fast
an object is traveling remember velocity
and speed are very similar the only
difference is velocity is a vector
quantity and speed is the scalar
quantity so first of all let's think
about what leaves me now if we have a
straight line going upwards like this on
a velocity time graph it means we have X
acceleration meaning the object is
getting faster that's because if we look
at after one second the object is
traveling at 1 meters per second at two
seconds it's now faster it's traveling
at two meters per second and after three
seconds all the way up here it's
traveling at about five meters per
second so it's getting faster it's
accelerating also it's good to notice at
the very beginning because the velocity
rights at the giving was zero meters per
second that shows if the line is here it
shows the object is stationary is not
moving okay next up now if we have a
horizontal line on a velocity time graph
like this this is showing it's moving at
a constant speed now we can tell this
because at three seconds it's moving at
five meters per second at four seconds
it's still traveling at five meters per
second and at five seconds it's still
traveling at five meters per second so
for this portion of the graph here it's
key
it's it just stays traveling at five
meters per second meaning is traveling
at a constant speed now finally if we
have this part here a line going down it
means we have deceleration that just
means it's getting slower it's slowing
down
because at the top part here it's
traveling at five meters per second but
over time it's getting velocity is
getting less and less it means it's
getting slower and slower until we get
down to here zero meters per second
which means the object is stationary so
it's a little reminder this object
accelerated started moving at constant
speed then slowed down in deceleration
now we can actually use a velocity time
graph in order to - in order to find the
total distance traveled because this
object has has been has been moving we
could actually use our speed equals
distance over time equation to find the
distance of this objects move so if
we're trying to find the the total
distance we need to do speed times time
well in this case velocity times time
and by doing that we need to find the
area underneath the lines underneath
this part of the graph so first of all
we're going to have to split it into
different sections so we can find the
area of these different shapes so first
of all let's do it for the first portion
of the graph here so to find the to find
the area of this section here it's a
triangle so to find the area of a
triangle we need to do 1/2 times base
which one here is 3 seconds times height
which is 5 seconds so 3 times 5 seconds
so 3 times 5 is 15 half of 15 is 7.5
meters you could use a calculator for
this but for this video I'm just going
to do them in my head okay so 7.5 meters
so after this this past portion above
here the object has traveled 7.5 meters
so what I'm going to do next is I'm
going to look at this next portion of
the graph I'm going to break it down
it's a smaller chunk so I can find
of each of these different shapes this
time I've got a rectangle to find the
area of rectangles really nice and easy
it's just base times height now be
careful because I'm gonna find this is
this is my measurement here for my base
not all the way all the way from here so
it's between three and six so it's one
two three meters in total so I'm going
to do three times my height which is
five so that is 15 meters so the final
thing I need to do is I need to find my
area for the this section of the graph
where we're decelerating we're slowing
down again I've got to find the area of
a triangle so funy area of a triangle
ready 1/2 times base so it's between 6
and 10 seconds so 1 2 3 4 so times
height and my height here is 5 so 4
times 5 is 20 half of 20 is 10 meters so
all I need to do to finish off is I need
to just add these together because uh
this portion I've traveled 7.5 meters
this portion of the graph I've traveled
15 meters and at this portion of the
graph I've traveled 10 meters so my
grand total that's 25
I say 25 so that's gonna be 30 to 32
point 5 meters I've traveled in total so
that is how to use a velocity time graph
thank you very much